why do I put myself through this I may
as well jump in and eat old now go on
jump you're terrible anyway I don't
don't do it man
you got so much to live for I kind of
have most of the loop
are you serious Lance we don't have any
thicken time for this Merrick you come
on me Zack
you take care of Adam we'll meet you in
the next circle come on Adam
it's just mean you know let it out
what's up what's got you down
it's the shotguns I just can't figure
them out yesterday I was in the final
two with this smoking-hot military girl
girl you know it wasn't a girl right
most like you have fat 35-year old man
living needs a mother's basement all
right point made can I get back on with
my story yeah go ahead
she suddenly flinched so I shot her
square in the face but it only hit up a
nine damage bro that's happened to me
countless times you just got to go of
him man and to make it worse she started
dancing oh that's gotta hurt I moved
forward shot her in the face
nine damage again oh man what happened
next
I just stood there like an idiot and
then she put me out of my misery
tough break man okay listen up I'm gonna
make you a shotgun gut what okay so what
I want you to do is I want you to pump
and then jump switch the attack shoot
it's that simple honestly I'm not sure
Zach I think I'm gonna go play h1z1
instead okay peer pressure wins let's
try this one more time Adam do you hear
that that's right that's destiny Colin
go get him okay let's do this he's
beginning to believe yes Adam great work
Adam you are ready for the next step
what's the next step
free your mind you are now hyped buddy
Oh hold up what the hell am I wearing
I look like Bugs Bunny sex toy just go
over please
okay you're the boss
[Music]
the back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
see the bloodshot gums are great so does
this mean you're converted it was nice
but shotguns on noobs okay this is
exactly why your mother never loved you
[Music]